Studies.
Have you personally had any experience with interdimensional beings?
Well,
because it's all taboo and people,
let me tell you,
I have my hundred percent tell us about it.
Doing DMT.
I 100% communicated with something.
The question is whether that's something was actually in my imagination or in my
mind or that something was something that takes place in another dimension.
I don't know.
I can't be sure.
There's no way to put it on a scale.
There's no way that throws you run it through a task,
but what I do know is that it's the same experience.
I can be sure.
Okay.
I mentioned Eric Muller,
who you know a man Maquel Mahler because he's the one guy willing to let me tell
the story.
I've literally talked to,
I see a hundred people.
It's probably more than that because I've known about this for a long time.
He is a Christian,
but he heard about all this,
so he went down to a couple places in central South America and did it twice.
Both Times.
It was 30 to 40 people in the group and he's like,
well,
Alex,
I just don't believe in demons.
But I did.
She basically aliens coming to the edge of the forest and we were all sharing it
and come on,
we're all seeing the same thing,
but I think it was a chemical reaction.
You don't have,
if you,
everybody gets drunk.
We all think about what happened to us in high school or college or what's good
or what's bad.
We all have different experiences.
When you're taking on a hallucinogen and suddenly you're all seeing the same
thing,
it just means it clicked off.
The part of your brain is a filter.
It's you go crazy because a lot of schizophrenia and people just see more and
then they see everything.
It doesn't mean they're right.
It just means that the filter is off.
Well,
I always said,
you'll give her,
run your hand over an insect that can't see.
They have no idea you're there.
They like certain insects.
They just don't see anything,
whether it's a centipede or whatever.
And how do,
how do we know what they see?
We don't know.
You're right.
We,
we,
by dissecting dead ones,
we have an understanding of what sensors they possess and we can we think a,
B,
a,
B or a fly sees like in a bunch of little,
like I told hexagon that they have different,
yeah.
We don't know what the exact experience was.
I told you the whole story got computers hooked up to the damn bugs.
They've got everything hooked up to the bugs.
The differences,
let me tell you.
Yeah,
they've got roped up 35 years ago.
They had remote control rats with microchips.
They could send 500 yards of the alarm dot building shit with a camera on their
top.
They had 30 years ago to dolphins too,
right?
Yes.
Trapped.
They've gotten this dolphins head main line,
scientific American roaches with a chip on their head that run around.
The difference is the where the reason that's dangerous is that once you open
that gate,
it's all bad.
They has it all bad.
Why?
Why can't you experience that interdimensional being in learned something from
it and be a better person who you come out of it because for whatever reason,
at first it's all beautiful.
It's showing you're an ass tech base.
Catnapping all the local tribes and killing whoever's the tall for the smartest.
Every time it gets control,
it starts murdering everybody and it always starts beautiful.
It always starts crying.
So you're talking about ancient civilizations with a ritualized psychedelic
drugs and they up killing everybody on every case and every case the priest say
we have to pro babies are the fires.
We have a cut their hearts out.
We have to buy congenital.
True or false.
Supposedly the mushrooms were used by the Aztecs so that they wouldn't resist.
They'd get them all high on mushrooms.
It was beyond that.
We had a cocktail at a cocktail.
They don't resist dozens of hallucinogens.
Intox was they'll give him an enema.
True or false though.
They didn't use mushrooms just to keep them sedated so they get near ground.
It makes sense if you get it,
they killed.
Pull this up.
I think the temple,
I,
I forget how you said t t o con too,
Ican,
but in this one tempo,
I think they killed some insane amount of people after it was constructed as
after the construction's tens of thousands.
They sacrificed tens of thousands of people that,
the ones that we're actually working to build the temple once they killed
everybody and real real university hedge.
Who I,
I want to hear from them.
These are the Mayans.
And they said,
yeah,
no,
we're opening here at dimensional gate.
The gods want blood and they didn't take it internally to the mouth.
They would take enemas of dozens of hallucinogenics and alcohol and show the
priest would take a couple of drugs and then the priest wanted to communicate
with the aliens and the aliens wanted blood and they also show it was more like
we're chopping hearts out.
Yes sir.
Okay.
We did a thousand.
The Gates Open.
Here it goes.
Jamie says,
it says they between two.
Wow.
Between 10,040,
80,000,
400 persons were sacrificed,
sacrificing the ceremony in 1487 when the Aztecs,
uh,
completed the temple.
And how do you say the temple named pull up the,
the the top of it.
How do you say good.
It's uh,
it's all over.
How do you say the temple name?
Oh,
it doesn't say that's matching your city.
Tila con I think I'm saying she goes shit each where they think they killed
about 5 billion people.
Flushing.
This is one day fucking insane.
They killed 80,000 people in a couple of days.
That's banana.
That's come out of the way.
You go down there and you're walking around in the woods and the Mayan guy goes
the bones and they pick up and you're like,
it's not gravel.
It's petrified.
Bones are everywhere.
Oh my God.
Let me go further.
The priesthood were meet sellers.
This happened in Europe as well.
They would hang people up and the stores,
the market is below the temples and show you would eat the meat and the most
valuable meet was warriors.
Like when you won the ball throwing game that went on for days,
they would kill you.
They killed you.
The ones who won were murdered.
This is the thing.
They used to think that they sacrifice the losing team.
Now they realize the sacrifice,
the winning team.
I had a bit about for awhile where I was like,
that must have been the longest fucking game ever to see such a drop in the ball
fucking up.
They were all fighting because they wanted to fund.
They believe they were.
Yeah.
They shed quits caught Lopota on the flying serpent.
[inaudible] the quality app is going to,
you're going to interface,
you upload to its brain and you look at their paintings.
It's all like space ships and dials and they have perfect in the Spanish museum
for 200 years previous on a hoax because there's,
there's,
there's drawings of a 200 year old Spanish,
uh,
textbooks,
but you know,
see it a a,
it's about like a half foot long.
It's a,
it looks like a jumbo jet with the windows and the engines.
Two or false.
The Mayans smoked penis blood.
They did.
What they did was I made that you were just being silly.
No,
no.
That's true.
Selves that they took.
They took long lines of leather.
Chad wore leather and it had it had it had nails on it and,
and,
or had like spiky things that glass and they would put it in their genitals.
Oh,
the most skilled priest,
the high priest,
while they were sacrificing people for our thinking,
hallucinogens would,
would like not try to cut his testicles off,
but all of the most skilled would sit there and draw them through their smoke,
the blood
toxic to their ancestors.
The lower the lower priest within pulling up to the answer,
they would put it on sacred leaves and then they would smoke the genital blood
of the high priest and they would talk to the ancestors.
I believe it's just fun.
People are so goofy.
Look,
if you see those African ladies with a giant plates in their lips,
if you believe that other,
the next,
yeah.
How about that?
They stress their necks out to the point where if they take those things out
ahead,
head will fall off.
People are willing to do all kinds of crazy things to their body.
I'm not surprised they,
they'd smell blood.